Salut ! Aujourd’hui on va fermer cette géode.
Wow c’était incroyablement facile, je pensais
pas qu’y aurait aussi peu de résistance.
Comme un 49.3
Allons observer cette géode dans mon accélérateur
de particules… oh déjà midi ? Génial,
j’ai faim !
Approche, petit.
Un peu moins.
Voilà, ça c’est bien.
Avant d’aller plus loin à la découverte
des merveilleuses merveilles de notre sous-sol,
il te reste un truc à savoir.
Et ce truc, c’est que la géologie n’est
pas une science.
C’est bien plus que ça.
C’est une vocation, c’est une philosophie,
c’est une grammaire, c’est un cap, c’est
une péninsule, c’est une fille, félicitations,
nous l’appellerons Pédiluve.
Non plus sérieusement, le dernier truc à
savoir pour mériter votre ceinture blanche
de géologie, c’est qu’il existe trois
types de roches.
Celles qui comprennent la logique, celles
qui ne la comprennent pas, et les autres.
Les premières à s’être formées sur Terre,
ce sont les roches magmatiques.
A l’origine, notre planète était une boule
de magma en fusion qui a refroidi… pour
donner des roches magmatiques.
Jusqu’ici, ça va, mais un peu comme les
mesures du gouvernement en matière d’écologie,
ça manque un peu de concret.
Munissez-vous tout d’abord d’un magma.
Bon apatite !
D’ailleurs, vous avez pas besoin d’acheter
votre magma en supermarché, vous pouvez le
cuisiner vous-mêmes.
Il vous suffit pour cela de prendre une péridotite,
de la chauffer, de la comprimer, et/ou d’y
ajouter de l’eau.
Ce qui permet d’abaisser le point de fusion
de la roche.
Elle fond à plus basse température.
Et paf ! Ca fait du magma.
Cette belle pâte plus ou moins visqueuse.
D’où son nom d’ailleurs, ça vient du
grec « massein » qui veut dire pétrir,
malaxer.
Et contrairement à ce qu’on pense, en général
le magma n’est pas complètement liquide.
Y’a aussi des gaz dissous et des grumeaux
qui se baladent.
C’est soit des bouts de cailloux arrachés
à la roche encaissante ou tout simplement
des minéraux qui ne sont pas fondus.
C’est pour ça qu’on parle de fusion partielle
de la roche
Eh oui, souvenez-vous.
Dans un magma, tous les minéraux ne cristallisent
pas à la même température : l’olivine
se forme dans un four bien chaud alors que
le quartz se contente d’une fin de cuisson,
pour prendre les deux extrêmes.
Eh bah c’est pareil dans l’autre sens
: le quartz fondra à basse température,
l’olivine à haute T.
C’est pour ça qu’on se retrouve avec
du solide et du liquide mélangés en un gros
tas informe.
Comme votre sœur.
Donc pour l’instant, on est sous terre.
A partir de là, vous avez deux options.
Soit votre magma reste là et refroidit bien
pépouse.
Soit il remonte en surface, et ça nous fait
un volcan qui érupte.
Dans le premier cas, on obtient des roches
plutoniques.
Parce que cette poche de magma, une fois refroidie,
on appelle ça un pluton.
Et comme notre soupe refroidit tout doucement,
ses atomes ont le temps de faire connaissance
avec leurs voisins et de leur tenir la main
pour former des beaux cristaux qu’on voit
à l’œil nu.
Comme le granite.
Ca faisait longtemps que je l’avais pas
dégainé celui-là ! Tous les minéraux se
touchent (comme des youtubeurs à une convention),
ils sont bien gros bien visibles, c’est
magnifique.
C’est ce qu’on appelle une texture grenue,
et c’est typique des roches plutoniques.
C’est ce qu’on retrouve en Bretagne par
exemple.
Les côtes d’Armor, pour simplifier, c’est
un pluton, donc une poche de magma qui a refroidi
pour donner du granite.
Mais si on regarde ça de plus près, c’est
pas un pluton, mais plusieurs enchâssés
les uns dans les autres.
Quand le premier est apparu, il s’est ensuite
fracturé.
Et du magma est remonté dans les trous, qui
en refroidissant nous a donné un deuxième
pluton, ce fameux granite rose.
Et re-fractures, et re-pluton ainsi de suite
à la va comme j’te pousse avec d’autres
granites, gris puis blancs.
Parce que la composition du magma a changé
entre temps.
Donc en très très gros, et de loin (les
spécialistes vont me tuer), les côtes d’Armor,
c’est des poupées russes de plutons.
Et après ça, les couches de terrain au-dessus
ont été érodées et tous ces granites enchevêtrés
ont affleuré en surface, comme du beurre
dans un kouign amann.
Voilà donc pour nos roches plutoniques.
Du côté des volcans, c’est beaucoup plus
rock’n roll.
Quand le magma atteint la surface et qu’il
devient de la lave, cette lave une fois refroidie
nous donne des roches volcaniques, comme le
basalte.
La particularité des roches volcaniques,
c’est qu’elles sont soufflées.
Parce que dans le magma, il y a aussi des
gaz dissous.
Et ces gaz s’échappent avec quand ça remonte
en surface par une toute petite cheminée,
c’est sous pression.
Et du coup ça va donner généralement des
roches pleines d’air, soufflées, donc assez
légères.
Et quand les dieux de la géologie débouchent
les volcans telle une bonne bouteille de mousseux,
la lave est expulsée plus ou moins violemment,
comme des migrants aux portes de l’Italie.
C’est un peu la panique à bord.
Ses atomes ont pas le temps de se dire bon,
alors comme on va rester là encore un peu,
toi Bob tu prends la cabine 58, Jacqueline
tu prends la 12, Jean-Saucisson la 4.
Non, c’est plus genre « sauve qui peut
! » arrêt sur image, générique.
Donc, comme la roche est refroidie brutalement,
les minéraux seront plus petits, ils auront
pas eu le temps de pousser.
Ce qui fait qu’on les verra rarement à
l’œil nu : on appelle ça une texture microlitique.
Et si on regarde tout ça au mimicroscope
on verra qu’ils baignent dans un espèce
d’amas amorphe, comme votre sœur après
son AVC.
C’est ces fameux atomes complètement en
vrac qui ont pas eu le temps de s’organiser
pour nous voler notre travail.
C’est ce qu’on appelle du verre.
Le cas le plus extrême, c’est ça.
Du verre.
De l’obsidienne, pour les intimes.
Et on le reconnaît à sa cassure très typique,
comme quand on brise un cul de bouteille en
verre.
Dans le métier, on appelle ça une cassure
conchoïdale, j’adore ce mot.
Je compte sur vous, à la prochaine bagarre
d’ivrognes à laquelle vous assisterez,
vous pourrez ramasser des débris de verre
et montrer aux gens cette fameuse cassure
conchoïdale.
Et ils seront tellement heureux d’avoir
pu s’instruire grâce à vous qu’ils arrêteront
instantanément de se quereller et qu’ils
se battront plutôt ensemble pour un avenir
meilleur.
Et voilà pour les roches volcaniques.
Figurez-vous qu’on en trouve aussi en Bretagne,
ça tombe bien.
C’est un peu le paradis des géologues,
la Bretagne.
Et pas uniquement pour son porto, sa morue
et son tango.
Sur la presqu’île de Crozon il y a des
anciennes coulées de lave sous-marines, des
coussins de basalte (ou pillow-lavas) qui
ont 450 Ma, l’âge de raison.
Donc il y a près d’un demi milliard d’années,
la Bretagne était déjà sous l’eau.
Sauf qu’à l’époque, il y avait des volcans
en plus.
La légende raconte qu’ils crachaient du
caramel au beurre salé.
Donc pour résumer, parmi les roches magmatiques,
notre première catégorie, on a d’une part,
les roches plutoniques qui cristallisent en
profondeur et sont toutes belles toutes grenues,
et d’autre part, les roches volcaniques
qui se forment en surface et qui sont soufflées
comme du pop corn.
Et ça, avec le même matériau de base : du
magma ! Si bien qu’on arrive à en faire
des couples de roches ! Pour une même composition
de magma, si la roche refroidit en profondeur
ce sera un granite, en surface c’est une
rhyolite.
En profondeur, si c’est un gabbro, en surface
c’est un basalte. esssétéra.
Et bah vous savez quoi, on y est, on y reste.
Les Bretons n’ont pas que des roches magmatiques,
des chapeaux ronds et des enfants consanguins.
Ils ont aussi un deuxième type de roches
que j’aime beaucoup : les roches métamorphiques.
Regardez-moi ces beautés.
Ce sont des cailloux qui ont été malmenés
par la vie, par exemple qui ont été au contact
d’une poche de magma, et qui ont cuit.
Du coup, elles changent d’apparence.
Comme Tata Odette avant et après l’été.
Vous voyez bien que c’est la même personne,
mais elle se ressemble pas du tout.
Bah là c’est pareil : si vous comprimez
la roche dans une chaîne de montagnes en
formation, ou que vous la chauffez sans aller
jusqu’à la faire fondre non plus, ça la
métamorphise.
Et son réflexe, à cette pauvre roche qui
n’a rien demandé, ça peut être de créer
des nouveaux minéraux comme le grenat, ou
bien de faire des feuillets.
Elle aligne ses minéraux, sous l’effet
de la contrainte.
Comme quand on est dans le métro en heure
de pointe et que la rame est déjà pleine
à craquer mais qu’y a quand-même 50 connards
qui montent.
On sera serrés, on prendra moins de place
en largeur et on va tous grandir de 20 cm.
C’est scientifiquement prouvé.
Bon, contrairement à nous, les minéraux
vont en plus s’aligner tous les uns à côté
des autres, ce qui peut être utile pour laisser
le passage à ceux qui voudraient entrer et
sortir de la rame, nous on n’en est pas
encore là.
On est moins évolués qu’un schiste, quand-même.
Enfin, sauf en Corée du Nord, là-bas les
gens sont bien disciplinés, ils font pas
des grèves à tout-va.
Puisqu’on parle de schiste, un exemple ordinaire
c’est l’ardoise ! Celle sur laquelle vous
écriviez quand vous étiez à l’école,
car vous avez 80 ans, ou bien celle sur laquelle
vous mangez votre burger sans gluten avocat-thon
rouge avec sa sauce aux baies de goji et sa
salade de graines germées, arrosé d’une
pinte d’IPA brassée localement.
Mais y’a pas que les schistes et les gneiss
: y’en a aussi d’autres, les marbres,
les éclogites, les amphibolites, les métagabbros…
Bref, y’en a plein.
Ce qui est magique, c’est qu’on peut reconstituer
ce à quoi ressemblait Tata Odette avant l’été.
Enfin reconstituer c’est un bien grand mot,
mais on est généralement capables de dire
que c’est une caucasienne de 50 ans qui
regarde Scènes de ménage et pas pour la
poitrine de Liliane.
L’ardoise par exemple, c’était de l’argile
compactée.
L’amphibolite, c’était du basalte.
Le marbre, c’était du calcaire.
Eh mais, j’ai parlé d’argile et de calcaire.
On n’avait pas encore parlé de ça, ne
serait-ce pas des exemples… du troisième
type de roches ? Mais oui, les roches sédimentaires
mon cher Watson !
Je vous ferai pas l’affront de vous expliquer
que c’est des sédiments transformés en
roche.
Donc les roches sédimentaires, c’est des
sédiments transformés en roche.
Si vous vous rappelez notre bienheureux sable
Raoul d’un épisode précédent, ce Raoul
est né de l’érosion d’une autre roche.
C’est un sédiment.
Le plot twist, c’est que Raoul peut redevenir
une roche ; du grès.
Ce grès, c’est un exemple de roche sédimentaire
détritique, formée comme son nom l’indique,
de détritus.
C’est aussi le cas du poudingue, ça a une
tête de nougat sauf que c’en est pas.
C’est une plage de galets fossilisée.
J’adore le poudingue.
Mais vous vous serez doutés, il y a d’autres
types de roches sédimentaires évidemment
! Ca serait trop simple sinon.
Celles d’origine chimique, qui sont formées
quand l’eau s’évapore et que certains
éléments qu’elle contenait précipitent.
C’est comme ça qu’on fait le sel ou le
gypse.
Et enfin, les roches d’origine biogénique
(on en a un peu parlé dans la vidéo sur
le sable).
C’est celles qui se forment au fond des
lacs, des mers et des océans par une joyeuse
accumulation de cadavres.
Eh oui, parce qu’un beau jour, les baleines,
les poissons, le plancton, tout ça ça meurt.
Et quand ça meurt, ça tombe tout doucement
au fond de l’océan, ce qui crée une espèce
de neige féérique.
Chaque couche écrase un peu plus la précédente.
Et ce cimetière marin va finir par s’indurer,
et donner du calcaire, parce que les squelettes
sont en calcaire, comme nos os à nous.
Et voilà le travail.
Et si vous me demandez quel est mon calcaire
préféré, c’est une question un peu bizarre
mais pourquoi pas, alors je vous montrerai
ceci.
Douvres.
Calais.
Le D-Day.
Le jour le plus long.
Débarquement immédiat.
Qu’est-ce qu’on a fait au bon Dieu ? Les
Visiteurs en Amérique.
Les Bronzés 3.
Des souvenirs intenses des plus sombres moments
de notre Histoire.
La craie, donc.
C’est un type de calcaire très pur constitué
uniquement de squelettes d’une famille de
phytoplancton qu’on appelle coccolithophoridés,
et je sais pas si je préfère leur nom ou
leur tête.
Non mais regardez-moi ces bouilles !
Et voilà pour les roches sédimentaires.
C’est des sédiments indurés, qui sont
au choix d’origine détritique, chimique
ou biogénique.
Et c’est dans ces roches-là qu’on trouvera
des fossiles.
Uniquement dans celles-là.
Si vous en trouvez dans des roches pas sédimentaires,
c’est qu’y a une pouille dans le cottage.
Point Bécassine, reprenons notre lave en
coussins.
Cette lave a coulé au fond de l’océan,
sur des sédiments.
Eh bah c’est en regardant les fossiles contenus
dans ces roches sédimentaires autour qu’on
a pu dater ces pillow lavas en question.
Puisqu’ils étaient de la même époque.
Voilà, donc tout est connecté.
Et c’est même pire que ce que vous croivez.
Tout est tellement connecté qu’on parle
carrément de cycle géologique.
On en parlait un peu au début : il y a 4
milliards et demi d’années, notre bébé
planète était une boule de magma en fusion.
Puis elle a refroidi doucement en surface…
pour donner des roches magmatiques.
C’est donc la première famille de roches
à être apparue sur Terre.
Ensuite, l’eau de pluie a érodé ces cailloux
pour donner des sédiments puis des roches
sédimentaires.
Une fois que la tectonique des plaques était
en marche, ces roches ont été bousculées
et heurtées les unes contre les autres et
paf ! Voilà des roches métamorphiques.
Lesquelles pouvaient se faire éroder à leur
tour pour devenir des roches sédimentaires
ou fondre pour redonner du magma puis des
roches magmatiques.
Plus généralement, si vous prenez n’importe
quelle roche, vous la faites fondre, ça devient
du magma… puis une roche magmatique.
Vous érodez n’importe quelle roche, en
faites une autre avec les restes : ça devient
une roche sédimentaire, comme un grès.
Vous chauffez-comprimez une roche magmatique
ou sédimentaire, ça la métamorphise, comme
cette ardoise.
Et vous pouvez l’éroder ou la transformer
en magma à nouveau si ça vous chante.
Et ainsi de suite.
Et ce cycle-là, ça nous paraît une évidence
à nous autres géologues, c’est le genre
de trucs qu’on apprend en arrivant à la
fac.
Mais figurez-vous que ça fait pas si longtemps
qu’on le sait.
L’idée est apparemment née à la fin du
XVIIIe siècle et elle aurait mis plus d’un
siècle à gagner le cœur et l’intellect
de la communauté scientifique.
Tout commence chez les Lumières écossaises,
dans la tête de James Hutton.
C’est un peu le père de la géologie moderne,
et accessoirement le bro de David Hume et
Adam Smith, pour ceux d’entre vous qui sont
intelligents.
(Pour Monsieur phi, du coup.)
En 1785, James Hutton expose sa toute nouvelle
Théorie de la Terre à la Société royale
d’Edimbourg.
Il s’est dit : et si notre planète bleue
était en fait une poubelle jaune ? Et si
elle passait son temps à se recycler ? Prenez
du matériel fondu, qui est entraîné dans
les montagnes, montagnes qui sont érodées,
ça dégringole jusqu’aux mers où ça devient
un sédiment… bon on commence à la connaître,
cette histoire.
Et il se dit, je cite, ouvrez les guillemets,
« même les plus vieilles roches sont des
ruines d’anciens continents ». Il baptise
ce grand huit des cailloux le « grand cycle
géologique ».
Ah j’avais oublié que j’aimais pas le
café.
Cette idée s’inscrit dans une théorie
plus large, esquissée par Hutton puis affinée
et raffinée par le géologue écossais (encore
un) Charles Lyell, un pote de Darwin.
Ils ont remarqué que les processus impliqués
en géologie étaient trèèèès lents (vous
pourrez pas vous construire une résidence
secondaire en pierres avec le calcaire qui
pousse dans vos canalisations par exemple,
pas tout de suite en tout cas).
Ils se sont dit : si ça se trouve, c’est
les mêmes processus qui ont formé la Terre
qu’on connaît maintenant, mais sur des
échelles de temps gigantesques.
Du coup, on n’a même pas besoin d’invoquer
Dieu, des illuminati ou des extraterrestres
pour expliquer les formations géologiques
qu’on observe aujourd’hui (coucou Deï
Mian), il suffit de regarder comment marche
la nature et d’imaginer la même chose sur
des immenses échelles de temps.
En d’autres mots, « le présent est la
clé du passé ». Ca, c’est ce qu’on
appelle aujourd’hui le principe d’actualisme,
et c’est un des piliers de la géologie
moderne.
Aujourd’hui, ce principe d’actualisme
repose sur deux éléments :
-le principe de régularité : si ça se passe
comme ça ici, ça se passait peut-être déjà
comme ça hier ;
-le principe de simplicité (ou rasoir d’Ockham)
: pourquoi faire compliqué quand on peut
faire simple?
En d’autres termes, on va déjà essayer
d'expliquer un maximum de choses avec les
hypothèses déjà admises avant de penser
à en ajouter d'autres.
Le paléontologue Stephen Jay Gould (le mec
du gène égoïste) a commenté ça en disant
wow génial, vous venez de dire que la géologie
s’appuie sur les mêmes principes que toutes
les sciences expérimentales.
Donc, la géologie est une science ! Cool
cool cool, ça nous avance vachement, c’est
pas comme si on le savait déjà.
Le truc c’est que, ouais, ça nous avance
un petit peu quand-même.
Historiquement, ce principe d’actualisme
a justement contribué à faire de la géologie
une science.
Parce que c’était pas gagné à la base.
Avant notre doublette en kilt, les géologues
pensaient qu’au commencement, Dieu créa
la Terre, lundi, du coup.
Certains tentaient même de faire coïncider
les observations géologiques et le grand
dégât des eaux de Noé.
William Buckland, le chef de file de cette
école de pensée qui faisait largement consensus
à l’époque, voyait même la géologie
comme « l’auxiliaire et la servante de
la religion ». Selon Gould, c’était carrément
« une enquête quasi-théologique qui visait
plus à montrer la grâce de Dieu qu’à
comprendre les processus naturels ».
C’est Lyell et ses disciples qui ont dit
que bon allez, il y a un temps pour la religion,
un temps pour les cailloux, sauf en Arabie
saoudite, et qu’on allait plutôt prendre
modèle sur la physique.
Donc c’est au XIXe siècle que la géologie
a commencé à devenir une science.
C’est pas si vieux que ça.
Je vous l’ai faite courte, y’a plein d’autres
rebondissements autour de cette théorie de
l’actualisme, notamment quand on apprend
qu’un de ses concepts viole le 2ème principe
de la thermodynamique et contredit la théorie
de l’évolution de Darwin (c’est con quand-même,
Lyell et Darwin étaient super potes et leurs
théories étaient pas compatibles),mais c’est
pas le sujet de cette vidéo et j’aurais
peut-être l’occasion d’y revenir dans
un épisode dédié parce que c’est vraiment
intéressant, si ça vous dit faites-moi signe
dans les commentaires, et d’ici là je vous
glisse quelques références sur le sujet
dans la description.
Donc voilà, pour résumer y’a autant de
cycles en géologie que d’antidépresseurs
dans le sang d’un youtubeur.
Le cycle de l’eau, de l’azote, du carbone,
le cycle des marées, le cyclope Polyphème,
ma bicyclette, les cycles climatiques et le
cycle des roches qu’on vient de voir.
Il ne vous reste plus qu’à apprendre ce
schéma par cœur pour obtenir votre premier
dan de géologie.
Pour l’occasion, je vous ai fait un sticker
à retrouver sur ma boutique Utip et à coller
sur votre Kangoo à côté de l’autocollant
à l’aise breizh.
Merci infiniment pour tous vos dons sur Utip
et Tipeee, vous êtes des gens formidables,
je vous aime follement.
Pour la prochaine vidéo on va élever un
peu le débat, ça risque de vous faire un
peu peur mais ça va être cool, d’ici là
merci et bonne fête à toutes les Pédiluve.